Why couldn't we get enough masks? Why couldn't we get enough ventilators?
Why weren't there? The perception that there wasn't enough hospital beds,
how come the morgues couldn't keep up and so on and so on. Um,
how come we couldn't be prepared for this?
And no matter how you look at it at every area,
it was a failure of government.
As a Liberty minded person. As you said, if people don't come out of this, uh,
more libertarian, something will have gone wrong. What, what are the,
the proper approaches for a Liberty minded government? So say,
uh, a liberal, libertarian,
or classical liberal set of ideas that could get us through something
like this. What should we have done sort of at the beginning,
what should we have done as we're going through it right now?
And what should we be looking at for the future?
If you want to keep people as free as possible while also dealing with something
that we've never dealt with.
For Dave, if I were going to summarize my position in a sentence,
it would be something like this,
that medical professionals and the medical industry free of all
restrictions should have been allowed to deal with this virus from the very
beginning, without the intervention of politicians, period. I mean that,
that.
It, a red tape, just let them do their thing no more,
no more regulations on experimental treatments, that kind of thing.
Yeah. And not only that, but you know, if you think about it, Dave,
a lot of this flattened,
the curve analysis that led to the crackdowns and the mandatory social
distancing and the universal house imprisonment that we're dealing with right
now, um,
was due to the perception that the medical industry was unscalable in the event
of emergency. Now,
that's very interesting why people need to be asked question if it's
true, why was an industry unable to scale
industry is specialized in scaling. You know, when,
when people buy more of your product as an industry,
you're excited to offer more of that product or service to them.
What makes the medical industry unique in that respect?
Why couldn't we get enough masks? Why couldn't we get enough ventilators?
Why weren't there? The perception that there wasn't enough hospital beds,
how come the morgues couldn't keep up and so on and so on. Um,
how come we couldn't be prepared for this?
And no matter how you look at it at every area,
it was a failure of government. It was, the system was, was,
was heavily regulated. Uh, the strategic medical reserve,
disincentivized hospitals from it, from gathering their own, uh, supplies,
the tariffs on masks it's seriously inhibited.
And this is very personal to me because I have friends in New York who are
nurses and doctors who are resharing mass. I can't get enough.
And the tariff seriously injured that, um,
and the hospitals didn't have enough supplies on hand cause they assumed that it
was all there. The federal government was putting it all together,
but then of course they opened the warehouse and the half of elevators don't
work. You know, the supplies aren't there cause they had previously been,
been depleted. Every area, all you see is government irrationality,
but the inability of hospitals to scale the panic or the political class to
force everybody into their homes, which is definitely where you should not be,
whether you have respiratory disease.
The answer is to get outside is everybody understands.
You don't want to put old people with young people.
Cause that causes endless amounts of infections.
You actually want to isolate and separate the people who are vulnerable to this
disease, which are the old and, and uh, fail. Um,
and um,
the last thing you want to do is close the schools cause COVID,
as we know now is, is, uh, is actually not fatal for,
for young, healthy people. So at every single area, Dave,
the government has done the wrong thing and I don't know how long or how
detailed we want to get here. But the testing fiasco was the great,
I would say beginning of all this stuff, um, because uh,
China had already gone through a trial run of this stuff. You know,
we had this benefit of this.
We saw this coming and the CDC and the FDA stopped.
And this is a matter of record, uh, really stopped, uh, private, uh,
researchers from developing the test and distributing the test from the very
beginning of this crisis. That was a catastrophic thing.
And that led to what I've called, pardon me, epistemic crisis.
We didn't know. We didn't know who had it, whether I had it, whether you had it,
what we should do about it, how it was transmitted,
who is vulnerable to the fatalities, what the case fatality rate is.
We didn't know anything.
So we replaced knowledge that we could have used with power
and panic. And here we are.
So is one of the inherent problems that we have fighting the
bad ideas that would encroach on our rights. That even if you lay out to people,
well, here's all the things that government has done wrong, all the,
all the way. And here's why it can never work properly that they always say,
well, that just means we meet.
We need more government that just needs means we need to give it more money.
So it can be bigger so that we can put more studies out there to make sure it
knows how to do these things.
And that answer always sort of sounds easy and right,
for people that aren't really thinking, it's much harder to say to people, Oh,
the government actually should have been scaled way back on this so we could
have let the professionals deal with it. That,
that sort of sounds scary to people,
especially at a time right now where we feel like the future is just up in the
air right now. Yeah. I, and.
I think this speaks to a little bit of, uh, something, uh,
a principle that's animated your career in your life,
which you had a passion some years ago,
a realization that people don't appreciate, uh,
freedom.
They don't have confidence and freedom that freedom was being
attacked fundamentally and philosophically by both the left
and, and, and on the right too. And I think you worried about that.
You actually asked yourself a very important question,
what happens, uh, in the event of a crisis where we need freedom more than ever.
And yet we don't have the intellectual foundations in place where there's not a
cultural love of this thing.
We call freedom or an under much less than understanding of it.
What happens then?
And I think that was a very interesting perception that you had, um,
uh, you know,
several years ago that you really dedicated yourself really hard to this,
to this problem and, and, and tried your best to do something about it.
But I think what we're seeing right now are the results of a culture that is
that's, that's forgotten the meaning of freedom, that, that,
and what if you lose that? What do you replace it with?
It's you replace it with the police state with not good with,
yeah.
So right now, as we, as we sit here,
all sort of trapped in our houses, trying to figure out what to do,
how concerned are you about some of those basic freedoms that we're talking
about? I mean, right now, the, the right to assembly, for example,
we cannot assemble together. You know,
you can't get 10 people in a room to do anything. We had our,
our bizarre mayor, um, being nice, uh,
de Blasio in New York city say that if he found temples or churches that were
having any gatherings, they could be permanently closed. Now, again,
I'm all for the, the six foot social distancing,
if that's what the professionals are telling us,
but the idea that we could permanently close these things and we can't assemble
or our right to free speech in that we know that even right now,
big tech is removing blog posts that run counter knowledge.
That's not necessarily, um, the government stepping in and doing it,
but just if we look at just some of our key freedoms, assembly,
and speech being the two at the moment,
how concerned are you that we're just going to sort of put them aside throughout
this, and then it'll be six months later and we'll go, Oh, we had those things.
Yeah. I think anything is possible right now, Dave,
and anybody who says otherwise,
hasn't been paying attention over the last couple of weeks. There's no chance.
So I looked, I re before there, before we met up,
just now I looked back at what I wrote January 27th. Cause I, I,
I wrote an article warning that the quarantine power could be used and, and,
and explained why this is a very, very bad idea.
But even in that article, um,
I imagined something like this, that,
that the government would set up like quarantine areas,
which in fact they have done and they would come knocking on your door and grab
people out of it,
maybe one family at a time and put them in there in the quarantine area where
you know,
that they would target maybe neighborhoods and round
everybody up and put in Paddy wagons to put them in the quarantine area.
But even January 27th,
I never imagined that governments of the world would put everybody
under what amounts to house arrest. So the fact that,
that this has happened, I would say at this point in things anything's possible.
I, I worried cause we put out a book last week called coronavirus and economic
crisis. Um, a book put out by American Institute for economic research.
I put it on Amazon and I got to tell you, I was worried.
I was worried that Amazon would take it down. So I printed, uh,
separately some, uh, lots of copies, uh,
independently with an independent publisher, um,
and started making it available on the website,
just in case that we face massive censorship.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.